In this recitation, we'll be
going over the basic steps
in building, solving, and
analyzing a linear optimization
model.
The problem we will
use to demonstrate this
comes from Google AdWords, which
is the advertising system used
by Google.
Let's begin by talking a
little bit about Google.
As you may know, Google is a
major company in the United
States that provides
products and services related
to the internet.
Google's official
mission statement
is to organize the
world's information,
and to make it universally
accessible and useful.
Although Google today
develops a variety of products
that includes things such
as the Android operating
system, the Google Glass
wearable computer, and even
self-driving cars,
Google became famous--
and is still most widely known--
for its search engine, which
can be found at www.google.com.
The search engine lets
the user enter a query.
Google then searches
through the web pages
accessible on the internet,
to return links to websites
that best fit the search query.
Now, how did Google come about?
Well, the idea of
Google originated
as a research project
of two people--
Sergey Brin and Larry Page.
This was in 1996,
while they were still
graduate students at
Stanford University.
Their idea, in a nut shell,
was to measure the importance
of a web page to a
particular query,
not just by measuring how much
that query occurs in that web
page, but also by considering
the links to that web page
from other web pages.
They quickly found
that this idea could
form the core of
a search engine,
and they found that the
search engine actually
worked quite well.
They eventually named it Google.
And in 1998, they incorporated
Google as a company.
In the same year, they
received their first funding.
At the time, they had a database
of 60 million web pages.
Six years later, Google's
initial public offering
took place, and Google became
a publicly traded company.
After going public,
Google has continued
to grow at an immense pace,
acquiring other internet
companies like YouTube in 2007.
In 2013, Google's traffic
reached more than a billion
unique monthly visitors.
Today, more than two-thirds
of all the searches
done on the internet are powered
by Google's search engine.
Now, you may be rather surprised
to hear that Google does not
actually make any money
directly from its search engine.
In fact, Google's search engine
is free for anyone to use.
So then, how does
Google make money?
And the answer is --
through online advertising.
Basically, Google sells space on
its web pages-- in particular,
results of its search
queries-- to outside companies.
These companies can then
place advertisements, or ads,
on these spaces.
Let's take a look at
a concrete example.
So here we have a screen shot of
the results of a Google search.
The query here was "nine
inch nails tickets".
Nine Inch Nails-- if you're
not familiar with it--
is a critically acclaimed
industrial rock band
from the United States, that
recently toured North America.
On this page, there are only two
search results-- here and here.
The first is a link
to Ticketmaster,
which is a company that
sells concert tickets.
The second is to the tour
page of Nine Inch Nails'
official website.
All the remaining links
on this web page are ads.
In this case, these
are mostly links
to other third-party
companies that resell tickets.
Now, you may be asking,
why do companies
advertise with Google?
Well, there are several reasons.
As you saw a few
slides back, Google
receives a lot of internet
traffic, as a lot of users
conduct searches on Google.
So an ad placed
on Google could be
seen by a very large
number of users.
At the same time, Google's web
pages-- and the ads in them--
are formatted in a very
clean, visually appealing way.
Lastly, companies that
advertise with Google
can select which queries their
ads will be displayed for.
This is a very useful feature,
because a company can then
target specific
customers that they
think are likely to
buy their product,
or to use their service.
Google's online advertising
system is known as AdWords
and is responsible
for more than 97%
percent of Google's revenues.
In the next video, we'll
go into more detail
about the components
of the AdWords system.